to work racist seems that some believe
so LA Times reporting that for people of
color remote work gave them a reprieve
from racism they don't want to go back
in it the author claims many black
workers and other people of color found
that remote work lessened the racism
they faced on the job throughout the
pandemic survey after survey showed that
what some workers of color have known
for years workplace politics and
discrimination can make the office an
undesirable place to be I just because
nobody really wants to go back to the
office but I was thinking about this
judge I'll start with you
um so the New York mayor Eric Adams
the D.C mayor Muriel Bowser and the San
Francisco mayor London breed are all
begging people to come back to the
office right because the cities are
dying this and they need people to come
back to the office
they don't think it's racist I
understand some people might have
problems that the office don't discount
that but is this the reason to claim to
not come back to the office well when
you think about it if you claim that
racism is a reason not to come back to
the office then what's the solution
segregation I mean think about how
backwards the whole thing is and in
terms of everything being racist I mean
what math is racist the infrastructure
is racist camping is racist all the
stuff we've talked about it's like look
with all the money that we're spending
on Dei and making sure that we have
people in companies who are in a
position to stop any kind of problem and
to move us forward according to the
progressive agenda then it seems to me
that you know you're more protected now
than you ever have been that there are
people looking out for you so you know
the truth is racism is the racism is the
answer to uh it's the end-all of every
argument it's racist so I can't do it I
think it's ridiculous and it's another
excuse and Jessica it's not
like a lot of these companies are not
asking people to come back to like
pre-2020 levels they're asking for two
or three days in the office so hybrid
work so even if you did have a problem
at the office and hopefully you don't
but if you did it would be less than
before
well and that's why majorities are just
going back to work but this article was
recounting information or research that
the author had done she's gone out into
the community and spoken to black people
who expressed this view it wasn't a
perspective that was being argued by the
author themselves and there was data in
it a survey from 2021 showed that only
three percent of black people who work
remotely wanted to return to the office
versus 21 of whites that's a pretty big
Divergence and one of the people that
She interviewed for this was talking
about the fact that if he went back to
his job in person he worked in a in a
hospital that he would have his
competency continually questioned that
that was something that happened to him
all the time when he was coming in just
to do his job they felt that he was
always being given the proverbial side
eye about how good he would be at doing
his job and
I don't I don't feel like I'm in a
position to be able to tell people who
actually suffer from this kind of
discrimination that they're being about
I will then be okay because I question
the competency of all of my staff and it
doesn't have anything to do with race
I'm constantly giving them the side eye
like really is that the best guest you
can book it has nothing to do with his
race bosses question employees
competency get used to it it was
patience in the hospital okay I don't
love doctors either they always want to
over operate I'm fine don't worry about
it I had to bring this up Jessica I
didn't want to but I'm not going to let
disinformation slide on the show you
bring up Omaha the first thing I Google
Omaha crime ABC ABC News look at the
rates how one city cut gun violence in
half and may become a model around the
country you stepped at another race
let me let me my face is just fine
that's good to uh Greg on this you know
I read one thing today that a way to
solve all of this and get everybody to
really come back to the office happily
is to actually give everyone an office
and stop this open plan cubicle stuff oh
interesting because people don't want to
hear everybody else's nonsense this is I
this is not a funny story this is
infuriating I actually when I hear this
because it's phony it's phony this is
the data is I question all these all
this data on Race as we're finding out
more and more is fudged if the LA Times
honestly trusts this work that they
published their HR Director should go
down tomorrow morning and go to their
staff white people please come to work
black people stay home
go for it I dare you to do that you
can't because that is racist this should
piss every black person off this article
views blacks as a group all suffering
from the same problem they cannot see
the individual this is the root of all
of the the evils in our society the
race-baiting is because we're seeing
people as groups number two they see
blacks as a group that are too fragile
too fragile to be to handle being at
work what a destructive sickening excuse
imagine being black and some pushy white
HR liberal comes up to you and says oh
they must be hard to be back at work you
know maybe you should stay home you know
how does how if I were black and maybe
one day I will identify as black this
person who wrote this would be seen as
an enemy because what a way to prevent
achievement is to tell people that you
can not participate because the field is
too treacherous for you but not for us
for you think about how disgusting this
is I can't I cannot take this crap
seriously again if you take it seriously
I want to see Human Resources address
this so-called problem because the
so-called problem doesn't have a
solution right it doesn't have a
solution that's why they did this you
know also end up being called racist is
when remote workers don't get promotions
as men as on the same part in the office
if you said you know what you should
stay home that would be racist too right
so come to work racist stay home racist
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else